to present the next award we have Goldie
yep
wait a minute there aren't gonna be any
more awards that plant that mean green
mother from outer space he's raising
hell backstage because there's no
category for Best Performance by a plant
he just stayed true in the claim but now
he's hitting the price and Waterhouse
well here's one Oh ISM star of Breakfast
Club and pretty-in-pink
the pretty Miss Molly Ringwald
at work of this year's nominees for best
achievement in film editing ray Lovejoy
for aliens
Susan amours for Hannah and her sisters
Jim Clark for the mission Claire Simpson
for platoon Billy Webber and Chris Leben
Zahn
for Top Gun
and the winner is Claire Simpson
thank you very much Academy it's great
honor I want to thank all of the stone
Thank You Oliver he gave me a very
wonderful material to cut I'm very lucky
and I want to thank my crew I share this
with you Tom David Julie Scott Toto in
Philippines and all those friends that
have supported me through my career my
good friend Dede Allen Malcolm Clarke
don't treat my family thank you all very
much